there are new signs today of the
avalanche of backlash following Prince
Andrews BBC interview about Jeffrey
Epstein now his future role within the
royal family may be in question
Elizabeth Palmer joins us from outside
Buckingham Palace Elizabeth good morning
morning everybody yes this interview was
supposed to make the issue of Prince
Andrew's longstanding friendship with a
convicted pedophile go away but actually
it's just added fuel to the fire and I
took the decision there was plenty of
scathing criticism here at home for his
tone widely viewed as arrogant but you
were staying at the house it was
convicted sex offender it was a
convenient place to stay in fact the BBC
interview was such a fiasco that Prince
Andrew the son of Queen Elizabeth has
become a liability for the palace
says royal correspondent Roy única and
the repercussions events have been
incredibly negative for him and you know
at the moment it feels like dangerous
times at Buckingham Palace and Prince
Andrew is drawing even more fire from
the US a woman known only as Jane Doe 15
filed a lawsuit Monday alleging she was
trafficked to epstein for sex I was
contacted by one of Jeffrey Epstein's
assistants and invited to up Skeens
Island where I was told Prince Andrew
among others would be a guest in the end
she didn't go Jane Doe has not accused
Andrew of any wrongdoing and he's not
mentioned in the lawsuit but her lawyer
Gloria Allred says he has an obligation
to tell American investigators whatever
he knows about Epstein it's the
honorable and right thing to do I think
it's his duty to do it what the Prince
does next remains to be seen some advice
that mocking Paris might be suggesting
that he lies no for a little bit until
this potentially dies down all the dust
settles but I suspect he will want to
carry on with business as usual but that
may be impossible for all kinds of
reasons including the fact that there
are thousands of documents filed in a US
Court case that
be unsealed anytime soon and further
implicating Anthony no I don't think
this is gonna die down Elizabeth Palmer
in London thank you